bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 sport allez on passe
tout de suite au sommaire de cette
édition c'est la saison de la
confirmation pour le plaisir handball
devenu le team 78 fruit d'une entente
inédite entre quatre clubs yvelinois le
groupe d' alexandre taillefer entend
bien gravir un échelon supplémentaire
dans le championnat de france des moins
de 18 ans l' aventure s'arrête une
nouvelle fois en demi-finale pour
montini dos au mur les joueurs
d'alexandre couton se sont inclinés ce
week-end face à l'équipe fédérale et
laisse s'échapper la finale de division
2 cet été les cadettes du cercle
nautique de versailles sont devenues
championnes de france d'aviron en 8
un titre que le club attendait depuis
106 ans l'occasion de s'arrêter sur la
discipline reine de l'aviron évidemment
comme d'habitude en fin d'émission
l'essentiel des résultats du week-end
mais tout d'abord place à notre page
spéciale handball je le disais dans les
titres de cette émission c'est la saison
de la confirmation pour le plaisir
handball devenu le team 78 une entente
inédite dans le département et pour en
parler de cette alliance
l'entraîneur de l'équipe est présent sur
le plateau du 7-8 sports alexandre
taillefer bonsoir messieurs merci d'être
là
alors avant de parler un plus
précisément de ce concept de cette
alliance de quatre cabines moi je vous
propose de regarder un reportage pour
présenter un petit peu cette équipe
les règles n'ont pas changé toujours le
même sérieux à l'entraînement toujours
le même entraîneur alexandre taillefer à
la baguette
en revanche ce qui a changé à plaisir
pendant l'intersaison ce sont les
joueurs
après avoir prôné la stabilité qui a
permis aux yvelinois d'accéder au
championnat de france le club a créé une
entente départementale montigny le
chesnay versailles et plaisir évolue
désormais sous le même maillot du team
78 serait que le groupe a été renouvelé
à moitié c'est un humain c'est important
en plus notre dispositif a changé parce
que arriver de nouveau
joueurs eux
m'a semblé important de le changer mon
dispositif pour que l'équipe sur la plus
performante possible et pour l'instant
c'est en bonne voie
en principe le règlement autorise trois
arrivées par intersaison autant dire que
cet été l'effectif a été remodelé et
pour tamponner les faits révolution la
préparation du groupe a débuté mi août
avec deux victoires et deux défaites
lors des matches amicaux
les joueurs semblent prêts à relever le
défi conscient d'avoir la chance de
participer à cette aventure savait plus
de compétent concurrence et plus de
compétitivité et ça permet à ce que on
soit à fond à chaque entraînement est ce
que les joueurs progressent plus vite
parce que si après on se repose sur le
sur le fait qu'on peut être directe
titulaire ou à l'entraînement c'est plus
trop ça et après les matchs en baisse
d'intensité c'est entendre semble en
tout cas avoir les moyens de décrocher
quelque chose en fin de saison
mais pour cela le groupe heavy noah
devra d'abord finir parmi les trois
premiers de sa poule pour se qualifier
en seconde phase
alexandre cette alliance toute nouvelle
dans les yvelines semble partir sur de
bons rails
expliquez-nous déjà un petit peu comment
le projet est né alors le projet est né
d'une idée que j'ai eue avec victor gana
guèye directeur sportif de plaisir qui a
été relégué ensuite par le président de
galles francisco afin de pérenniser cet
équipement du championnat de france
qu'on a eue a plaisir à l'année dernière
m'a semblé judicieux de créer une
entente pour que l'équipe soit
premièrement plus forte et qu'elle reste
sur la durée à ce niveau là et donc on a
invité tous les clubs des yvelines à
venir en faire partie cette entente et
montigny versailles le chesnay sont
répondus présents donc on est très
content c'est plutôt bien parti et est
ce que justement il ya un vivier assez
important de joueurs pour créer une
entente aussi aussi importante en nombre
deux clubs oui oui je pense que il faut
pas s'arrêter à quelques clubs je pense
qu'il faut laisser la porte ouverte à
tous les clubs puisque quel que soit
leur niveau de jeu en jeune il peut
toujours avoir dans même des petits
clubs entre guillemets un joueur
important et dans les gros clubs
bien évidemment en termes de quantité et
de qualité aussi la sélection j'imagine
a été drastique drastique par non pour
pouvoir repérer les postes où vous aviez
peut-être dément par rapport à votre
effectif de base
oui qu'on a fait les journées détection
il y avait jusque là on était un petit
peu surpris jusqu'à une quarantaine de
joueurs qui venaient à l'entraînement
donc il a fallu tout le mois de juin
un petit peut réduire le groupe au fur
et à mesure pour que pour qu'il y ait un
groupe en gros d'une vingtaine de
joueurs qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
sélectionnés et puis les s'entraîne avec
nous oui je leur rappelle là vous avez
un groupe fixe en tout cas de seize
joueurs qui sont qui sont disponibles
pour vous ça change de la saison
dernière où il y avait un petit peu
moins de joueurs à disposition
est ce que pour l'entraîneur que vous
êtes ça vous a obligé à vous remettre en
cause la vous le dites dans le très bien
dans le reportage vous avez changé le
dispositif statique la façon de jouer
ça vous à ça vous a un fléau si un petit
peu tout ça oui bah déjà ça me permet
d'avoir plus de possibilités avant plus
de joueurs plus de gauche et aussi
notamment ce qui nous manquait l'année
dernière - circulation de balle
donc à partir de là on peut envisager
d'autres schémas tactiques en attaque
et puis en défense ça nous offre plus de
possibilités et ne pas se contenter de
faire quasiment qu'un seul dispositif
que d'en avoir au moins deux donc c'est
une bonne chose d'avoir du nom et du
loup en qualité plus de joueurs
compétitifs ça veut dire aussi plus de
concurrence comme le disait notre
capitaine dans le sujet justement
l'entraînement il ya toujours ce même
sérieux c'est ce qui m'a un peu surpris
quand je suis venu parce que contient
des niveaux bas il faut prendre les
repères tranquillement ça fonctionne
bien tout ça
oui déjà on a repris depuis mi-août donc
ça faisait déjà trois semaines
quand vous êtes venu nous voir
l'entraînement mais de façon je pense
c'est quelque chose qui me caractérise
le sérieux à l'entraînement et c'est que
par là et l'apprentissage qu'on arrivera
à réaliser des victoires et et le plus
possible et cette entente c'est aussi un
passage obligatoire si j'ose dire pour
pérenniser le club à ce niveau qui est
le championnat france oui puisque toute
façon cette entente est une parmi
d'autres dans la france
à peu près 20% en temps de se créer
chaque année ce qui est assez important
donc si on n'est pas un club
professionnel pour pouvoir être à la
page en restant à ce niveau là on est
quasiment obligé à court terme de venir
faire des ententes et pour le staff est
ce qu'il ya une petite sensation de se
dire on écrit quand même un petit peu
l'histoire du handball yvelinois à ce
niveau oui ça c'est je trouve ça assez
sympathique de que vous le dit comme ça
c'est vrai que c'est une première pour
les yvelines je sois ans garçons et en
filles
donc j'espère que il y aura aussi une
entente chez les filles qui se créera un
jour ou l'autre c'est vrai c'est
tellement difficile chez les fils et les
ententes 1 c'est un peu plus complexe il
ya moins de jeu évidemment à disposition
lui trouver un club un peu moins
d'engouement mais je pense que c'est
tout à fait réalisable par rapport à ce
premier match parce que ça arrive vite
c'est ce week end que le championnat
reprend vous débuté sur le terrain de
paris galaxy qui était dans une de vos
poules l'année dernière vous allez
commencer en terrains connus mais c'est
important de tout de suite gagner et
prendre de la confiance
oui surtout que je reste encore en
travers de la gorge la défaite qu'on a
eue d'une quinzaine de buts l'année
dernière à paris et j'espère et
j'attends des joueurs du moins de ceux
qui avaient été présentées les dernières
une révolte parce que c'est pas
tolérable orgueil par rapport à
l'objectif sportif de cette saison
évidemment l'entente existe j'imagine
qu'il va falloir faire mieux que la
saison dernière avec plaisir tout seul
alors évidemment que quand on fait une
entente ce pour espérer faire mieux que
le vin seul club
mais encore faut-il le prouver sur le
terrain et il suffit pas de créer une
entente est de mettre des joueurs les
uns à côté des autres pour faire mieux
qu'un seul club l'année dernière
l'année dernière notre force ça a été
notre solidarité on nous attendait pas à
ce niveau là on a démontré parce qu'on
nous attendait pas maintenant la
difficulté est plus grande puisque on
nous attend on est connu on a une
entente il ya plus d'attentes
donc il va falloir répondre encore plus
présent à l'entraînement et en match
pour pouvoir faire ces résultats qu'on
attendait mais l'objectif minimum c'est
quoi c'est déjà de passer la deuxième
phase arrive va évidemment de passer en
championnat de france en indivision
bien évidemment et ensuite d'essayer en
fonction de la poule qu'on aura d'aller
le plus haut possible dans cette
nouvelle poule très bien on suivra ça de
très près évidemment déjà avec ce
premier match sur le terrain de paris
galaxy ce samedi merci beaucoup
alexandre dénonce massés sur le 7-8
sport et puis je le dis aussi aux
téléspectateurs on vous reverra dans un
autre costume puisque vous allez
intégrer l'équipe du 7-8 sport en tant
que nos consultants handball voilà très
bientôt
alexandrie après sa relégation nationale
de basket sans transition l'entente le
chesnay versailles est revenu un peu aux
sources comme on dit l'entraîneur de la
montée en une
vink au bar dietsch a repris du service
pour démarrer un nouveau cycle avec
plein de jeunesse un montage de xavier
jal se croirait revenu un en arrière
l'époque où l'entente clocher versailles
valider sa montée en nationale une
après une saison sabbatique loin des
terrains vinko berdych a repris du
service en remplacement de stéphane
drolet et le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que la méthode vinko a fait mal je
peux vous dire que on l'a senti surtout
physiquement surtout physiquement
moi personnellement j'ai connu que lui à
versailles entre la saison passée en
national mine avec stéphane drolet
je suis habitué les nouvelles ont un
petit peu de mal à versailles ses
banques un nouveau cycle qui démarre car
six des joueuses présentes l'an dernier
ont quitté le fcv pour compenser l'exil
le club a fait venir trois nouvelles
recrues
l'expérimenté lituanienne agustin aziga
été et les jeunes charlotte duquesne et
marine bord aux habitués du niveau
national la relève prend ses marques au
fil des entraînements et les bonnes
choses il joue qu'avec une célèbre
l'intérieur en bas comme je suis plus
dans le tir tout ça se fait intéressant
il adapte bien des thèmes parfois en
qualité pied coup avec ce mélange de
jeunesse et d'expérience les
versaillaise joueront le haut de tableau
en sont-elles capables
éléments de réponse lors de la première
journée avec la réception de trégueux
aller en par direction le maroc pour le
25e rallye des gazelles
elles viennent de valider leur
inscription pour cette 25e édition du
rallye des gazelles alice vosgien et
sandrine buffet originaire de
rambouillet se lance dans l'aventuré du
désert marocain pour la toute première
fois elles sont présentes sur le plateau
du cetud sport bonsoir à tous les deux
mais toutes les deux par non merci
d'être là
alors première question vous venez de
valider donc votre inscription
c'est déjà une belle étape en soi parce
que c'est un premier parcours du
combattant
vous allez participer à votre tout
premier rallye raid
alice dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
complètement vers l'inconnu l'idée
c'était justement de relever de nouveaux
défis parce que avec sandrine on aime
bien avoir quelque chose qui nous change
du quotidien et donc justement on va
vers vers cet inconnu là mais on s'en
approche et maintenant on est impatiente
de faire les stages de conduite et stage
de navigation pour être un peu plus d'an
concret justement j'allais j'allais
venir après pour la phase de préparation
vraiment concrètes
votre état d'esprit à vous de votre côté
sandrine c'est aussi l'envié de faire un
projet hors du commun un petit peu parce
que c'est une aventure extraordinaire à
l'heure à les vegas est complètement
déjà c'est une aventure avant je pense
cependant est un peu après aussi et
surtout là on est on est un peu quitté
quand même hein
vous êtes lancés dans ce projet sans
prime parce qu'on avait envie de faire
quelque chose de différent faire une
empreinte une quelque chose qui qui
marquera notre esprit je pense à tout
jamais et vous êtes sportive à la base
un petit peu à l'aise et moi je suis
sportif
effectivement on est on fait de la
course assez régulièrement on a
notamment participé à la parisienne il
ya deux ans donc on fait une la course à
pied je suis assez sportive a évidemment
l'autre aspect du rallye cdo côté
mécanique il va falloir savoir se
débrouiller dans le désert c'est déjà un
peu votre cas vous vous ouvrez un peu le
capot s'est pas encore encore ça on
s'est vérifié lui cet embonpoint sous
une roue alors le cas de kate c'est
encore autre chose parce que c'est un
peu plus gros mais oui on va faire de
toute manière tout nécessaire pour
apprendre tout ce qu'il faut alors pour
la première étape évidemment
l'inscription il faut déjà regroupés et
réunir près de 15000 euros 1 14 me huit
cents exactement ça a été compliqué de
trouver des sponsors sachant le contexte
économique actuel
alice ça n'a pas été facile
effectivement parce que ben déjà il ya
toute une première partie où il a fallu
créer notre dossier de sponsoring pour
bas pour aller se présenter aux
entreprises et leurs alors expliquer en
quoi ça peut leur apporter quelque chose
mais après c'est toute la partie
démarchage est allé rencontrer les gens
on a fait on a utilisé plusieurs
méthodes on va dire on a envoyé beaucoup
beaucoup de mails on a téléphoné à
beaucoup de monde sans avoir
quelqu'un au bout du fil à chaque fois
et on se rend compte finalement que ce
qui marche le mieux c'est d'aller voir
les gens de faire du porte-à-porte
d'aller les rencontrer que ce soit
directement dans l'entreprise ou faire
ce qu'on fait on fait le forum des
associations pour rencontrer des gens on
était à la fête de la musique
donc voilà aller à la rencontre des
entreprises c'est ce qui marche le mieux
finalement qui est un peu votre vos
propres agents commerciaux en quelque
sorte vous avez réussi aussi à récupérer
gracieusement votre véhicule donc ça
vous a aussi permis d'économiser un
petit peu ça c'est la sphère de l'année
un petit peu quand même ça oui c'est
tout à fait inespérée
on savait pas si on allait louer si on a
les ont prêtés en acheter si on avait
les fonds nécessaires et voilà un
garagiste a bien voulu nous nous la
donner et puis ben allal est en
préparation réparation préparation et
puis après bah on a encore d'autres
surprises
le 4 4 évidemment obligatoire dans les
dunes parce que ça va être compliqué
dans le sable c'est je le disais un
parcours du combattant du début presque
à la fin avant d'arriver dans les dunes
comment ça va se passer à partir de cet
instant vous allez vous avez prévu des
stages de pilotage des choses comme ça
par exemple
alors effectivement ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure il ya d'abord un stage de
navigation qui est indispensable parce
que la particularité de ce rallye c'est
que c'est un rallye où on fait de la
navigation à l'ancienne où on n'a pas de
gps on va falloir qu'on perde nos
habitudes actuelles et qu'on apprenne à
lire une carte ati lit un compas une
boussole
donc ça il ya un stage qui est
fait par l'organisateur qui aura lieu au
mois de janvier ou février pas encore
les latinos en début d'année prochaine
et après le stage de conduite donc là il
faut simplement faire un stage dans un
centre agréé 4,4 centre de formation
agréé donc on a déjà contacté quelques
quelques centres dans la région l'idée
c'est de faire un stage à un endroit où
il ya des pistes en sable pouvoir
vraiment se préparer pour revenir au
budget évidemment les quatorze mille 800
euros ce n'est pas tout pour pouvoir
partir au maroc et sur les dunes il faut
encore regroupé beaucoup d'argent c'est
c'est compliqué cette deuxième étape on
va dire du projet ben elle est un petit
peu plus compliqué peut-être encore que
la première car on a fait beaucoup de
prospection et on a aussi vu beaucoup
usé beaucoup de notre relationnel
mais là
ça s'est un peu épuisé du coup faut
qu'on retourne dans la prospection
alors on a encore quelques contacts
encore heureusement qu'ils vont
certainement nous aider mais il faut
encore qu'on trouve environ 8500 9000
euros
et du coup bah c'est un sacré sacré
enveloppe pour revenir aux pratiques qui
va piloter entre les dunes est ce que
vous avez fait votre choix déjà où ça va
être interchangeables les positions
c'est interchangeables et c'est surtout
conseillé d'être de changer le rôle d'un
jour sur l'autre parce qu'il ya 10 à 13
heures de conduite par jour donc ce sont
des journées très lourd ces neuf jours
de compétition donc un terme physique
c'est assez lourd mais effectivement
normalement ce qui est fait c'est un
jour on conduit un jour on navigue
histoire de de ceux de passe est prise
il de pouvoir interne est justement au
niveau physique vous allez vous préparer
spécifiquement les des footings d une
préparation physique louis il a l'air il
ya plusieurs choses à préparer il ya le
haut du corps parce que il faut préparer
les pectoraux pour pour soulever les
pneus désensabler tout ça il y a le dos
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de secousses
donc qu'il faut muscler le dos et puis
un peu d'endurance aussi parce que bas
par le co pilote va vous souvent aller
au devant de la voiture pour aller
contrôler le terrain et du coup fait
dans le sable c'est en tout cas le début
d'une belle aventure on vous suivra tout
au lond pour voir comment se prépare ce
premier rallye raid pour vous on verra
évidemment j'espère vos stages de
pilotage et puis jusqu'au départ au mois
de mars merci beaucoup à tout les deux
d'être passé sur le site sport et à très
bientôt
sans transition passe à l'aviron je vous
en parlais dans les titres de cette
édition cet été les cadettes du cercle
nautique de versailles sont devenues
championnes de france d'aviron en 8
un titre que le club attendait depuis
106 ans la date de sa création en somme
l'occasion de s'arrêter sur la
discipline reine de l'aviron montage de
romain rugby
c'est dans le froid royal que les
nouvelles championnes de france cadettes
s'entraînent ce matin là si le moindre
de leurs coups de rame semble en
parfaite symbiose
comme presque naturel ces jeunes filles
ont dû apprendre à ramer ensemble car en
aviron le 8 cela devient tout de suite
plus compliqué mais aussi plus agréable
quand cela fonctionne comme si ces huit
jeunes filles ne faisait désormais plus
qu'une sur l'eau le 8 c'est avant tout
vraiment la cohésion du groupe
on a compris cette année que pour faire
avancer suite fallait qu'on rame à 8
fallait être ensemble fallait former
qu'une seule personne c'est l'exercice
le plus difficile effectivement mais
c'est aussi le plus gratifiant pour les
rameurs passe quand même le bateau qui a
le plus vite donc le pis le plus
difficile aussi c'est que c'est des
filles
donc il faut réussir un peu aller les
amalgames et à ce que les caractères
puisse amalgames et surtout qu'on avait
quand même quelques caractères fondant
le typage des mises au point qui ont
provoqué un début de saison un peu en
dents de scie mais ce bateau a permis de
créer un vrai groupe autour de la quête
du titre et c'est lors d'un stage de
préparation aux dernières vacances de
pâques que le 8 des championnes de
france prend forme
après une première course de série
remportée face au grand favori
grenoblois les versaillais tiennent le
choc en finale pour décrocher ce titre
qui échappait aux huit royal depuis 106
ans la discipline reine celle des
patrons de la ram je la lis pas je suis
triste c'est pas possible en fait
j'avais là le seul truc que je voulais
c'était s'arrêteront dans mes bras et
bravo et si j'y croyais vraiment bas moi
je me dis c'est pas possible
avec tout ce qu'on a vécu cette année
c'est vraiment un très beau cadeau un
beau cadeau pour l'histoire du club
et dire que la plupart ne rament que
depuis deux ou trois saisons
elle devrait encore flotter sur l'eau
pour un bon moment
allez on passe à l'essentiel des
résultats du week-end
on commence par du baseball et je le
disais dans les titres laventure
s'arrête une nouvelle fois au stade des
demi finales pour montigny deuxième de
la saison régulière de division 2 les
cougars semblait en position favorable à
l'autre de ces playoffs mais après deux
défaites lors du match aller face à
l'équipe fédérale de toulouse les
joueurs d'alexandre couteau n'avait plus
le droit à l'erreur pour espérer s'en
ouvrir la porte de la finale de d2 ce
week-end l'espoir n'aura pas duré bien
longtemps il faut l'avouer puisque
montini s'incline dès le premier match
samedi 16 à 5
les cougars en toute nouvelle fois mal
digéré la coupure estivale
les années passent et se ressemblent
chaque fois on est on finit en demi
finale ça s'explique parce que bien que
la coupure c'est vrai que là on finit le
championnat en juin et reprend septembre
donc il ya deux mois et c'est vrai que
malgré malgré les reprises c'est
difficile
c'était ce qu'on avait prévu au début de
l'année les play-offs après on perd une
on perd la demi finale c'est toujours
décevant mais sur l'ensemble de la
saison c'est quand même une bonne saison
donc déçu aujourd'hui mais avec un peu
plus de recul dans quelques jours
sincère mais en football se jouait ce
week-end le troisième tour de la coupe
de france 10 16 club yvelinois et est en
lice on a sélectionné quelques résultats
vous le voyez trappe s'est imposé à
rambouillet 4 buts à 1 magny les hameaux
passes face à hardricourt sur le score
de 2 1 cela passe aussi pour versailles
à clamart 1 à 0 bilan globalement
positif pour les clubs illinois qui se
donnant rendez vous au quatrième tour
chez les femmes après sa relégation de
d2 montini joué son premier match en
division 2 heures à juvisy redémarrage
en demi teinte pour lésiner montaigne
qui ramène le match nul 2 buts partout
de l'essonne et vous allez le voir au
classement montigny est donc troisième
de sa poule derrière saint denis et le
paris université club
prochain match encore à l'extérieur sur
la pelouse de rueil malmaison en rugby
début catastrophique pur plaisir pour
son premier match de fédérale 2 le prc a
été corrigée sur la pelouse de niort
candidat à la montée
57 à 0 ce dimanche vous avez peut-être
découvert le stock-car à garancière avec
le football
car 2014 pour vous résumer la chose
c'est une piste ovale de 200 m qui
pourrait lors d'une course normale
recevoir trois ou quatre voitures
et cette fois ci ce sont 26 véhicules
qui se sont élancés ou pour sous tous
les coups sont permis dans un
embouteillage permanent les pilotes de
doivent effectuer 20 tours le plus
rapidement possible rassurez vous malgré
des tonneaux et les nombreux
carambolages des pilotes ne risque rien
un spectacle qui a régalé le millier de
spectateurs présents pouvoir tourner un
petit peu en pouvoir pour pousser les
autres quoi c'est vraiment un tout donc
sa vie un petit peu pilotage entre
guillemets et un peu de finesse en
évitant les autres et en poussant
conquois pour les éliminer l'ambiance
est plus fait d'avoir toutes les
voitures qui se ferait dans c'est
toujours sympa donc voilà le côté
spectaculaire on repasse à tous les
jours qu'on aimerait bien être à la
place des personnes qui font ça vous le
savez saint quentin en yvelines
accueille de nombreuses courses à pied
tout au long de l'année le 12 octobre
prochain le désormais traditionnel
ekiden se tiendra sur la base de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
ce marathon en équipe de 6 ou de quatre
coureurs vous pouvez vous y avez vous y
inscrire pour cette sixième édition sur
le site internet de l'as ptt des
yvelines
une dernière info foot avant de passer à
l'agenda de votre week-end ou plutôt
ligue des champions pourquoi parce qu'un
liancourtois va participer à cette
édition 2014 2015 il s'agit de jean
philippe mendy né à elancourt cet
attaquant de 27 ans a fait ses gammes
sur les terrains de l'eau essais avant
de passer professionnel et de faire le
bonheur du club slovène m le mk maribor
il a notamment inscrit 15 buts en 34
matches la saison dernière il va donc
découvrir la prestigieuse ligue des
champions face à chelsea schalke 04
encore le sporting portugal
on passe à votre agenda du week end
juste avant de nous quitter tout d'abord
du handball de rendez-vous ce week-end
la nationale 2 lève le rideau chez les
femmes pour ce premier match
un grand classique du championnat
montigny reçoit le havre à pierre de
coubertin coup d'envoi à 20h30 ce samedi
il y aura du basket première journée de
nationale 2 également le fcv longtemps
que le chesnay versailles ouvrira sa
saison à domicile face à trégueux au
gymnase bel air au chesnay coup
d'envoi à 20 heures c'est la fin de ce
set 8 ports merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain même lieu même heure d'ici là
excellente soirée sur tv fille